well it is pride month and we love
celebrating all our favorite queer power
couples and that includes the new
romance between selling sunset star
krishnel
staus and non-binary australian singer
g-flip krishel made her relationship
public with the singer during the season
5 selling sunset reunion special which
aired last month that's right and
krishell got emotional at sunday's mtv
movie and tv awards as she was honored
with the best reality star award after
coming out while she also thanked her ex
and co-star jason oppenheim
i have to thank netflix our leaders
jason
and just really quick um
i knew about this nomination before i
had said you know anything about my
sexuality i'm not trying to get really
deep with you guys but the fact that
this was voted on after
means so much to me because i'm sure
you know how that was going to go and it
so much guys i appreciate it
and g flat
was also in attendance looking so proud
of their partner as they were also
caught on camera sharing a kiss
you're about to say something about that
you got you got moved by that yeah i
mean like that's so relatable i mean i
would say that like you basically
watched me come out of the closet and we
used to work together because i came in
when i first met you and it was very
like i date girls remember you were very
but yeah and i was like not unsure of
myself so i kind of understand what
she's saying like you know i came out
and this the voting opened for this
award after i came out i was worried
that you all would hate me like as a
queer person we're just not sure how
we're gonna sit like i was so nervous
when i came out that i would like lose
my kids tv job even though like that
would not happen hello but you just
think these like awful things or i
remember like my friend melissa was like
hey before you tell your mom like she
loves you and stuff but just like prep
yourself for like if she doesn't react
well and i was like oh yeah there could
be a world where my mom turns on me and
is like i don't want a gay son you know
what i mean like this happens all the
time no matter what position you are no
matter who you are
so i i totally understand that and and
it's relatable yeah and it goes back to
what we talked about at the beginning of
this show today when you're saying
education was the other thing that you
loved and you think about when you think
of pride month because that does
it helps maybe lead the way for people
that are like you were when you were
younger unsure of what's going to happen
unsure of where of where things are
going to go it took me a very long time
to come to terms with my sexuality i
think a lot of queer people now we see a
lot of
children coming out at an earlier age
and it just makes me so happy because i
don't know about you priyanka obviously
we're both queer people we both have
coming out stories um but i didn't think
back in the day that i would ever be
able to do something like this i just
really didn't because we didn't have
that representation on these shows we
didn't see it out there no it's like
shocking almost to think of it it's
shocking and it's just so powerful when
i see you know these videos that parents
post of their children saying this is my
child and they want to wear a dress
today and i'm letting them and i'm like
yes
yeah it's good because as a parent like
my mom said like the hardest thing for
her
having a son like me
was that she just worries how the world
is going to treat me because you can't
control that you don't want your child
to suffer you don't want your child to
hurt and you can you can make a
a household that is accepting and warm
and a wonderful place for them the
outside world is going to be oftentimes
a very different place and so yeah i got
you here now we have icons like priyanka
that yeah
that children look up that's true yeah i
was just telling you actually before
this that like now whenever
fans recognize me at shows they're like
oh i used to watch you on kids tv and
now i watch you on drag race and now i'm
following your career it's like nice
that like people have this like norm
that when they look back at the person
they used to watch on kids tv they're
like oh now they went on to win drag
race and now they're an international
pop star yeah and so i'll talk to
the old co-host from back in the day
i mean that's it hanging out right
it's great it's great